Rapport with the client is critical.
In your point of view, Mark,...
...has informal feedback led to any significant changes in the way you deal with clients?
I think it has made me more diplomatic in dealing with complaints.
I'd like to ask for clarification of what you mean by that.
Let me get a show of hands of the number of people here who have lost their temper dealing with complaints?
Lots of us.
I tended to do that too.
That was because my expectation was that I had to defend the product.
Now I acknowledge the complaint as a situation where the client is offering informal feedback.
Can we afford to ignore informal feedback from our clients?